hi everyone um I'm here today because I
think it's quite important for the
people who have heard about trading with
um GMA exposure when they come to the
channel and when they come to gbit try
to learn um they think that you know
because we have classic estate and Order
flow they try to go to the most advanced
tools but what I want to show you today
is how guest boot classic you know is is
is so good and I can give you a good
Edge in the market is the power of
position analysis in only one tool and
even myself and other kind of more
experienced Traders on using um guesses
posha in our day-to-day trading we're
still using classic right and I'm going
to show you today why so if you're new
to uh gamma exposure trading with gamma
exposure this is a good video you need
to watch because I'm going to explain
how you can take advantage of the market
how you can start with gub only using
this simple tool and yet so powerful so
let's dive in what's the foundation what
is gbo classic right if you can see Geto
classic is a l style histogram yeah that
show you what you see here is the gamma
exposure it give you two readings one's
by open interest and one's by and one by
volume right the one by volume is the
one that we are tracking the one we are
interested in right so in simple ter
terms what is it telling you it's
telling you how much institutional money
is being allocated into calls which is
the green one or into PS which are uh
the red ones right and in the middle we
have what is called the zero g which has
an interesting calculation and and I'll
explain that later but this is also a
very key element so anyway calls when
you see all these calls um basically the
profile is telling us that if there are
enough calls there are more calls than P
that might push the market up right so
all these bars extending to the right is
kind of bullish G exposure or it is a
bullish gamma exposure PS are the red
bars extended to the left which are
bearish gamma exposure right we have
something very interesting and and I'll
explain everything but it's the same as
the other estate and and is this estate
kind of um profile but I'll explain how
when we can see how the market
participants or the institutions they're
all positioning themselves in the
options Market on these thoughts with
these dots we can see when there are
adding more gamma exposure to the
downside for instance in this example or
when there are liquidating all the gamma
exposure in this example is I believe
the
very close Day end of the day if you can
see is like two two you can see like the
Market's been trending down and we can
see how all these participants in the
market are taking profits why because
this thoughts it telling us is it tell
us like 1 minute 5 minute 10 minutes and
30 15 minutes and 30 minutes ago where
all those negative gam exposure were
positioning before and you can see as
they move to the right so it basically
say that all these participants are
taking profits right and they're
reducing the gamma exposure but anyway
let's going to get with um more details
into this so if you want to have one or
two trades per day right High probable
trades with a high probability of
success right classic is what you need
right so why so the key to high
probability trades is trade only on the
major gamma levels right right so the
major positive gamma usually acts as a
resistance right think of this as a
ceiling when price hit this level or is
very close to this level market makers
they sell into a strend right making th
the PRI for the price to push higher but
it's not that the market makers decide
to sell you know uh Futures on this
level is that options participants right
they were positioning themselves on the
way up right and once they reach this
target they take profit it has to do
with something which is called uh gamma
25 and Gamma 50 which I going to explain
later and why these guys in the options
Market they prefer to take profits on
these levels right so this is this is um
this is trade number one basically you
have to wait for the price to go up to
the major positive gamma this is a
resistance you don't buy here what you
do is you sell in here right because
again options participants in the as an
example if they're been buying uh
structures in the options Market which
are bullish they take profits here and
once they take profits they basically
liquidate all the options positions
Market maker who has been kind of buying
Futures to hedge their this this
portfolio to H to be delta neutral once
all these Market participants start to
liquidate their positions he needs to
sell all the Futures that he bought
right so this is trade number one sell
on a strength sell on this ceiling right
don't sell in the middle here just wait
for the price to reach these important
and critical levels now the opposite of
that is to buy on major negative gamma
this acts as a support
sometimes you can buy just before and
put your stop loss below right this is a
strong floor right where market makers
buy into weakness so basically absorbing
absorbing all the selling pressure and
again is not that market Mark market
makers decide to buy into weakness is
that options participants who were
putting a structures of uh they trade
volatility but they put in instructions
with uh when the market goes down when
they go to these important levels they
they start to liquidate their positions
right they take profits it's like any
other Trader if you are sure in the
Futures markets you take profit
somewhere right these guys they tend to
take profits in the options markets
around this major negative gamma so this
is trade number two if you are sure for
any reason just think about take profits
here and if it's early in the day in the
day or midday be careful at the end of
the day but if you see the market reach
one of these levels you can go long on
this right so this is how you use these
two major positive gamma and major
negative gamma to enter a trade go short
or on sorry go short on on major
positive gamma right or if you're being
long this is the place you take profit
and go long in major negative Gamma or
if you been short you take profit here
okay now why this happen Trace with the
highest probability happens at these
level because they act as a natural
turning points or mean reverting right
as an example for US futures Traders if
you are buying NQ or
mnq into a major positive gamma right
you don't buy here because you're
running into a wall but if you wait for
the price to hit a mejor negative gamma
here that's where buyers step in right
and that's where you have two Market
participants stepping in these levels
you know because very sophisticated
Traders and very clever Traders they use
gamma exposure to see where they can get
into the market so you got two groups of
Traders basically taking a long position
here first is the options guys who take
profits from their sh structures right
it's like they taking profit so they
liquidate their short positions let's
put in that way because they trade
volatility is not a shorts position as
such but as they liquidate their
positions Market maker needs to buy
right to to cover the the Futures
they've been selling the market maker
has been selling to to be delta neutral
and also other sophisticated Traders
they know these gamma levels and what
they do they also buy the Futures right
so this is where where this level the
major negative gamma is uh the place is
that where buyers step in you know and
this offers a great opportunity we've
seen it we got statistics on this and I
use it I I you know I use the most
advanced Tools in gasbo but day by day
this is one of my main setups I I look
on this every day is one of my main
screens so why um why is this happening
you guys my my my you know yeah you see
a long green bar on the right a red um a
long red bar to the left so so why is
that why you guys must asking you know
guys why is Freddy telling me this to
buy here and sell here well the
mathematical reason and I'm going to try
to explain it very easily is the options
guys they they don't trade Direction
They trade volatility right and they
have to be aware of the Greeks probably
you guys have heard of of the Greeks
which are Delta gamma Theta charm bega
right but for Z DT and remember we are
trading Z DT options or I mean we're not
trading Z DT we're following the guys
who trade Z DT options because we trade
in the Futures market so for these guys
trading Z DT they have something which
is the gamma profile right so once once
the gamma profile reach um what is
called the 25 Gamma or the 50 gamma C
this is the this is the graph of the
gamma profile so as the stock price rise
let's say this is SPX I believe as the
SPX rise you see how the gamma profile
you know goes upward sloping and between
the 25 Delta and the 50 Delta of the 50
uh 25 gamma 50 gamma here is decreasing
you know this is like a bell curve so
what why is this important because as
the as as the gamma profile decrease
look the price is still going up let's
imagine this is um some option structure
which is um benefit if the price goes up
right basically they're buying options
let's say if the price keep going up
look how the gamma diminishes returns
right so when you trade options this is
the place where you take profits because
it doesn't matter if the price keep
going higher your returns are going to
be diminishing right we can see a he as
well on the Delta progression right
between the out of the money options
let's say this is an out of the money
options when they reach the 25 Delta
look how the exponential moves is what
happen with this is if if if you buy
options you want to sell it right at a
higher price So when you buy out of the
money options and they reach your 25
Delta this is the maximum kind of
appreciation in value for that options
once he pass the 25 Delta it goes to the
50 right and you see all this kind of
upward slope movement from the from the
Delta which basically makes the option
more expensive and if these guys bought
these options they want to sell it at
the highest price right what's the
highest um probability of selling with
the highest price here when you reach
the 50 Delta you see you see it by gamma
exposure and in here when the Delta the
the biggest move exponential let's put
it that way exponential move happens
between zero and the 50 gamma of the 50
Delta pass through that level yeah it
might continue to go up but look the
slope is not as as as exponential as the
first part and why is this important
because options
Traders they also especially for zero DT
they are scared of theta right Theta is
the derivative that tells them that
basically it's time which decrease the
value of the options right TAA goes
against the option as the as the option
approaches to expire which is at 4:00
New York time or ET time this Theta
minute by minute start to reduce the
profits from the options guys right so
that's why when these guys go to these
maximum levels that's it they get out of
it right if if they're they're bullish
in nature for any you know options
structure they're going to take profits
here and we know why because past that
point the returns are going to be
diminishing and the Delta profile the
Delta progression is not going to be as
exponential as before right and they
have Theta right so that's why when you
guys trade with um GMA exposure you also
have to be aware of the time it's not
the same if the price price reach uh
reach or goes down to the major negative
level at 10:00 in the morning 11:00 in
the morning that if it goes at 3 p.m.
right because at 3 p.m. these options
zero DT options they only have 1 hour um
to leave right so they expire at 4:00 so
they only have one hour and TAA TAA is
crazy honestly I've been trading options
zero DT and the way TAA
influence the price of these options is
crazy so that's why these guys on zero
you know we follow the zero DT options
so that's why they tend to take profits
here and we can take advantage of that
right as we can see now let's going to
see was in the control panel of cbox
classic so we can select the ticket SPX
or whatever I do recommend if you're
trading es right you need to follow SPX
or these guys already they have it you
can convert uh es into SPS so you can
you can select a bunch of of of options
even myself I trade uh nasda Futures and
Q I have it the my class in in SPS why
because this is this is despite this is
being an hedging instrument for um
institutions why this gave us a really
good profile really good targets right
I've done and and I can tell you if you
want to trade es follow the SPX right
then we can select the 90 days the zero
DT and 1 DT right when you select night
90 days and zero DT it might give you
more or less the same profile on DT are
options guys who trade the next day
these guys can manage risk more
effectively than Z DT think of this
think of Z DT if you go into formula one
right you're going to get a car and
you're going to drive a nice Ferrari
into Formula 1 so you have to be very sh
you know you're going to go at 300K per
hour so you have to be very careful of
all your geks Theta gamma all of the
charm Banner but when you trade 1dt yeah
you still going to a race but you go
slower right you have time to react you
have time to see how to manage your risk
so what we like to do we would like to
see Zero DT options and now and then
during the day I toggle to one DTE
because I want to see what are these
guys doing where are they taking profits
where are they taking their major
positions right and that's very
important now what's important also is
volume right but the real what we look
at is the net of gamma or the net guas
right the gamma exposure if it's
negative basically it's telling me that
in general the market is trending low if
it's positive obviously the the the vice
versa Market is trading higher I'm going
to explain how I use this in a minute
but keep an eye this is where you see
the net gets net uh gamma exposure and
you can see also the zero gamma I going
to I going to teach you how to read zero
gamma too in a minute and this is very
important the mass change gamma exposure
when you see this is what this is how
the biggest or the maximum change has
happened in the last minute 5 minutes 10
minutes 15 minutes and 30 minutes so if
if you are trading with G exposure and
Market is trending down it hits
your um major negative level and you're
long what you want you want to see all
this must change to go positive right
what what is this showing when it goes
positive showing that now everyone who
was selling options is buying options
right is is is all this kind of Nega
gative gamma is now being bought so when
they buy back any option position we can
see the gamma here so when you buy when
sorry when when when you sorry when you
buy here from the uh major negative
gamma what you want to see is all this
positive and also when you
sell on on major positive gamma you want
to see this m change to go negative
right
now as I said before let's going to talk
about the zero gamma Battle Ground right
this is where the fight happens and I'm
always aware of this zero gamma right
this is one of the most important but
less understood Concepts right so what's
the zero GMA the zero GMA is the level
where if you see the
profile you see like kind of two
profiles here you see like kind of care
profiles it's very difficult to see who
is winning right who is winning the the
buyers or the sellers the the the call
gamma or the put gamma is very difficult
to see with this kind of just profile
but this is why this panel is so
important so the net gamma exposure it
shows or look the sellers are winning at
the moment you know it's more selling
pressure but also the zerog G is such an
important concept right this is this is
act as um like a volume point of control
if you guys have seen the volume profile
uh Theory right where they do like this
um value area high value area low and
the
bog I mean the way I learn it when I
learned this is like you never trade at
bog why because bog is where buyers and
sellers are kind of happy trading to
each other there is no imbalance so
basically what you have in Bok is that
you have this kind of you know rangy
Market you want to go short Market
rallies you want to go low Mark long
Market you know goes down so you don't
trade a big po what you want to do you
know you want to uh wait for the market
to get away from b or trade at the high
notes or low notes but this is more or
less the same if you think about shirro
Gama as that bip is a place where you
don't want to trade when the price is
around this level you don't want to
trade right and and and as I said before
why because this is the play where
buyers and sellers fight now when the
price move away from from from zero GMA
now we have a visual representation of
who won that battle for instance in this
example we can see that the sellers won
that battle you know they were battling
around there and then they they won the
battle um also here when the price look
this is a perfect example you know price
went down you have a little bit of um uh
fight here around this major negative
gamma in the morning that was too early
in the morning so look the real
positioning on the market on that day
that was the uh 12th of March the real
zero GMA uh sorry negative major
negative gamma was around this level and
see how the price first first of all it
moves in the battle it moves from uh
above to below from below the zero level
right then it have some sort of um
tricky area goes down to the major
negative GMA and look how it bounce you
know bounce all the way back so this is
this is what I mean when when I say you
know if if you want to have a system
that give you one or two trads a day
high profitable trays this is getb
classic and as I said before despy I'm
using the latest tools of gbot I always
look into this always always look into
this every day right and and
and the next concept is very important
because um the zero GMA is the Battle
Ground but you will see some clustering
sometime you see you see the line is
perfect line you know price go up down
we have some clustering like clouds
basically what if you imagine you guys
tell me oh why do we have the perfect
line here and here is like up and down
up and down same in here up and down it
looks like goes back and forth but no
what's happening this is the battle the
battle between buyers and sellers you
know we can we cannot detect that battle
here we see some lines going to the left
some red uh lines going to the red uh to
the left sorry some green bars going to
the right but when you see Zog Gama you
see the real battle right you see this
guys fighting sorry here you see this
guy fighting is is who is winning the
battle he seems to be the sellers here
won the battle and then zero gamma
shifts
lower they start to battle again and
then the price crossed below zero GMA at
that time at this moment if you're
trading you should be thinking of
trading short no long why because we are
below the zero gamma and look how nice
the price tried to reach to this level
but then it goes down to where again
major negative gamma where the price
found some support and then have some
rally so if you have a look at this you
could have two perfect trades one just
wait for the price okay let's imagine
let's be realistic uh let's be uh real
on this imagine the price cross you know
we have the battle here price cross um
the zero gamma level so you went short
right what would you do if you go short
with five contract you take some scals
you take profit and left AA that's what
we do every day that's what I do every
day and and I post my trades in the
channel I left a runner and put a a stop
loss just above the zero g so I made
some money here because I went short
took profits left one or two Runners
they went stop out no harm and then
Market goes here and then start to
retrace again now if you see Market
structure if you see my other videos I
like to use I like to read the market as
a market structure and look we have a
high then we have a low then we have a
lower high and the price cross against
zero g that's where you go short again
right you take some profits on left some
Runners above the zero GMA and look how
nice that trade would have been right
then you take profits here so you make
all this money by following this simple
strategy
and he has some mats behind it has some
reality is is market like the big
institutions the market positioning in
the options Market that moves the other
markets right the Futures now if you
feel is it's not even 11:00 it's like 11
at like 10 I don't know 10:45 maybe so
then you take your profits and once you
see the market start to come back you
know you know all the options guys who
were taking this position down here this
is what they take profits right this is
the 25 of 50 Max gamma and we know why
they take profits so you can go long
because Market maker has to buy back all
all the shorts he took into the Futures
Market to H his position to HH his
portfolio so options guys take profits
liquidate their options and Market maker
has to buy back all the Futures so here
we go you go with them right you go with
the institutions that's that's why the
powerful That's The Power of get BOS
classic right now we were talking about
clustering right it means it means there
is war now this happens again obviously
if you want to take a long here and you
put your stop loss yeah that's fine
that's trading it's not 100% perfect but
look what happened now what you have
another clue you have this uh clustering
right it's it's a batttle up and down up
and down what is this telling you is
this is Shifting right again I wouldn't
take this position because I don't have
any negative major gamma right but but
look how it works all this is being
battled when you don't have a clear line
it's just battled between buyers and
sellers like calls and puts until
someone wins right now the other trade
that you could have take is go short
here now is the opposite of this one so
you go short again apologies you take
profits leave some rner maybe you get a
stop out here you go short again take
profits LIF some Rana okay and that the
day you would have made so good money on
this tricky day I remember this day that
was the 7 that was tricky I think it was
Friday or something like that on March
um but that's how you use the clustering
I don't say that you go and take a
position when you see the clustering
right but it means that after this
clustering the price tend to have like a
clear Direction don't enter on this
clustering but be aware that when this
happen the power is Shifting so we've
been trending down this is might be
shifting when you see this right and you
see how it change now let's go for some
examples of zero GMA now this is the one
that we just mentioned that was on the
seventh uh this is on the 10 of
March look how the market start you know
it was battled you see this clustering
here this clouds of Zog is not Al line
it's just Cloud it's clustering does a
battle right then the result is as I
saying this sorry I forgot to mention
once um you know once once once this
fight has finished you most likely will
see that the price tend to have a
direction right so here look it was a
fight you know clearly Sals took the
lead
you could take a short here and put your
stop- loss above here and look this is
your target this is where you would have
had made your money okay
now look how they cheve the max negative
gamma so if the max negative gamma stays
here I'm pretty sure the market would
have rally right because I know the
market the all these guys positioning on
on on PS we have take profits here but
look what happened they that that was
the day the market went down on the 10th
it was like one way down so look what
happened they shift the major negative
gamma lower so what is that telling you
is this Market is going to have a
continuation lower so what do you do you
just wait for a reversal wait for the
price to go and test the zero gamma if
it doesn't test it that's fine you don't
have a trade but look how it test it and
then you can enter here short with your
stop loss here you already make good
money here look you sorry you make all
this money you know you just raise a
little bit of your profits and then you
would have all these night trade up to
here this is your target that's what I
mentioned at the beginning this could be
your target or your entry but since
you're are sure this is your target you
know people using like 20 moving average
SS RSI macd you know all this
nonsense you know they get scared and
they get out quickly you know because
those those are logging indicators it's
nothing to do with Market positioning so
uh they would get out here they would
get a scar get out here on the short but
look you know this is position analysis
you know this is showing when the big
guys are positioning in the market so
that's fine you take your shorts make
money take another Shore and make an
amazing
money this is another
example look how the market was battling
here you see see what I mean the
Clusters is not a straight line licing
here but it's just up and down up and
down Market go down retrace and again
finds resistance on the Zero GMA that
wouldn't have been a nice short and
where do you take your profits again and
again and again I see this in the market
every day so look that's what I mean
with getport classic you can get one or
two trades like high quality trades in
the market look and this is your profit
you know you take profit here now it's
not even 11:00 in the morning right so
you have some time because options
expire at 400 p.m. so you could take a
long here out of this major negative
gamma you know sculp some leave a rner
take more profits you know goes down
here you get scared maybe you close your
position but now you see it's working
again so you could go long again and
take profits leave a rner and where is
your rner maybe to to the zero GMA but
again look the clustering look look the
price activity here and look what
happened with zero GMA you see when you
see Zog gaming clustering it you know
honestly this is amazing because you can
see the Battle of guys in the options
market so my job is not to be clever my
job is to go with these guys and when
there's this I know all these guys are
battling you know puts and call they're
buying they're selling it's just
crazy and again look this is Market
structure you got a you go like kind of
double top then you got a lower high so
you got a high a lower high a lower high
a lower high and then the price breaks
again you make some good money on the
way down you make some good money on the
way up but you can risk a little B and
go short and look this is your Target
and that's what I mean if you're using
you know all these nine moving average
simple you know the 9 the 12 the 21 the
50 100 200 whatever
you would get out on this little
retracement but when you understand the
power of Market positioning you know
these guys are the guys who move the
market no on RSI no on macd is the
actual guys this is the volume right if
if you know when I understood that
volume is what moves the market and then
when I understood with getb that I can
see who is putting that volume and where
they're putting that volume that's where
you make money look you would have made
so much money here as well and look the
clustering you see Zero Gama is trading
very nice down and then you see this
clustering so this is Battle someone in
the options Market wants to change the
current regime and they made it they did
it you know there was a battle here and
then they changed the car
regime once the price cross the zero
gamma you can go long put a stop loss
below and where is your target here
right so that's what I mean with this
CBO classic you can have you can have
one or two high quality trays a day
that's all you need you know you don't
need anything else and and guys I tell
you again I use this every day even
though I use order flow and state I
always look into classic you know this
is my main one this is how I started
with with gam exposure and this is
fantastic uh this is another
example you can see uh battle market
results U let's put it that way sellers
won the battle profit so you would go
short here take profits here now look
how they CH the negative gamma down
below right this is the 12th of March
right um a little bit of Market
structure would tell you oh we're making
lower highs and we have a support here
which is broken right I wouldn't
necessarily take a position here but I
I'll be aware that we are below the zero
Gama so we're in a downtrend regime if
you were short here and you manag you
know you went short when the market
cross the zero GMA and you're stop loss
in here let's say you took some profits
here and it's crazy and if you manage to
go short again for any reason look the
Target right this is the target the
maximum negative gamma but let's be um
let's be talking a second scenario you
went short here and you took profits
here right and you miss all the move
down this is formal you know one the
guys see they they miss the move oh I
miss the move I missed the move oh it's
going lower I miss the move I miss the
move you know what happened 90% of the
time they sell here and once they sell
Market oh sorry market rallies a little
bit and they get out in losses and then
oh Market start to get down and you know
they already lose their money here
if for any reason you manage your short
right and and you miss you know you took
profits here and you miss the whole
movement down no worries as I said to
some guys that I give some advice why
you worry just let the market goes to
this maximum negative gamma and go long
look yeah you probably miss this move
but by going long you make all this
money it's amazing it's fantastic
honestly this is position analysis this
is where the big guys in the market are
positioning don't tell tell me that the
market rally because you know 2,000
Traders around the world decided to buy
here and they move the prices up no way
the market rallies because big guys with
big pockets they put money on the
downtrend and once they hit the maximum
negative gamma look on once they hit the
maximum 25 and 50 gamma level they know
that even if the market keeps going
lower they're going to have diminishing
returns so what they do they take
profits that's it and Market maker who's
been selling Futures on the downtrend
while they have to buy back the Futures
I used to be a market maker in London
and I have to do this all the time I
have to hedge my Delta Des Spire was
Market making uh the derivatives in the
FX Market which is
forwards no options which is linear but
I have to hch my Delta so many many
times we have big flows from big guys
and maybe I can't tell it here since I'm
not working there anymore well we have
big flows from central banks you know
this Central Bank of England came with
huge money into the derivatives Market
that's fine derivatives Market is huge
but then I have to go out to the spot
Market to hedge my Delta and that's what
I was selling selling selling selling to
HED my Delta now we're talking about
options and this guy guys they are
nonlinear so they they they they have to
be careful of the Delta but they also
have to take care of gamma bana charm
you know all these derivatives and yeah
look that's why the market rallies
because these big guys have to buy they
liquidate their short positions let's
put it that way because they're options
structures and Market maker who was
selling the Futures have to buy back
amazing trade what's the risk nothing
you just wait for the price to you know
reverse and you put your stop loss here
which is you know you're not going you
know nine out of 10 times you're going
to have a winning position I promise
that's the statistics and where do you
take profits maybe you can take profits
here because you see the clustering and
you know that when there is clustering
there is Battle now you see this and you
can go long if you want you make some
you know you make some good money down
here you make some good money up there
you just buy here and put some stop loss
here right and then where is your target
wow your target is above here look the
major positive gamma but you have to be
aware that as time passes look always be
aware of time as time passes this Target
and if the price doesn't get there you
know it's going to be more difficult to
get there because these options are
going to Spire so by 3:00 your option is
going to Spire so you have to decide
what to do right if you want to take
some profits or if you want to just you
know just just leave your stop loss
somewhere and take some profits you know
you go like kind of double tops so you
can take your profits here but it's also
because of time it's not because this
doesn't work it's because of time and
also be aware this works because big
guys again they know that they're going
to go along here so they also bot uh
structures with the upside potential
right the same guys who were selling
let's say this structures in the options
Market they were buying structures to go
here they couldn't so most likely they
get out somewhere but you know two three
beautiful trades that's all you
need
now um we're going to talk about one of
the biggest mistakes uh trades make is
trading against you know the dominant
gamma flows so how you
can um avoid that well if we are below
zero gamma you don't take Longs unless
we are in a reach the major negative
gamma if you above negative sorry if
you're above the zero gamma and you have
a positive regime which I going to show
you how to do it you know you don't take
shortes well you see the market goes
down and down but you know your
probability is is is low so how can you
avoid bad Trace right we have this panel
on the right hand side and if Max Chang
gamma is red so if you see all of these
going red 5 minutes 1 minute 15 10 uh 15
30 minutes and the net gamma exposure is
also negative and we are below the zero
gamma you know you avoid Longs right
unless you hit the major negative gamma
you don't go long anywhere here if this
net of G is negative and all this much
change is negative your only go long
when you hit your max negative gamma
right which is this one now on the other
side on the other way if everything that
you see is green right you like this m
change G is green and your net gets is
green right you don't sell right so if
you're here you don't sell unless look
you don't sell
unless you you you hit a major positive
GMA right let me see if I go an example
here right that's that's here this one
so you don't selling here because we're
above positive gamma most likely Mass
change is green and net gamma exposure
is green so you're selling here right
that's where you make your money you're
selling here you don't sell anywhere
else look look if you try to sell in any
other in any other level we're in a
uptrend right so you would take a little
bit profit maybe a stop out little bit
profits a stop out but here you have a
nice move here and then you know price
try to go up again and you could sell
again and you put your stop loss very
tight and that's it well you make all
this money and you and you and you lost
a little bit right and and and that's
what you do that's how you use this
panel to avoid bad Trace right um so
basically by following this simple
framework you know you filter out by
trade and only take high probability
setups and again guys I use this every
day you know I use this and I just wait
and I use obviously other tools but this
one is my main one this is what I see
every day to see which regime I am if if
I am you know down this regime Max maama
is negative you know I wouldn't have sh
going short here anyway I don't go long
I only take profits here uh and then I
wouldn't go long here you know that's
how I use it and then I use order flow
and other tools to kind of scalp and and
add positions but listen if you're a
disciplined Trader and you want a system
with one or two high probability trades
you know like like good trades getos
classic is for you
okay and now why why classic works right
and and how classic detects the market
control yes so why work so well so in a
simple way what what getos classic do is
calculates gamma by netting out calls
and put volume at each strike and they
apply what is called a spline
interpolation right and they create a
smooth curve which is the curve of
dominance and they have some crossover
over points right that reveals control
so basically when when um when the when
the price crosses From Below to above
that kind of curve a sply curve that
basically is is telling me or the
control now is on the upside right but
if if that the price cross that y kind
of Y AIS uh of the curve you don't see
it here because that's that's a
calculation that is is is is behind the
scene but it's so good and it's so
clever that basically is telling you who
has control and when and how they have
it right so that's that's that's I know
I'm a guy who you know when I want to
use something I want to understand
what's happening so that's why guys I'm
telling you this is a an interpolation
it's a very clever mathematical way to
see at each point who has control you
know the calls or the PS so that's
that's how it is
now what it shows like it shows where
the market makers needs to H you know
the maximum and minimum gamma also if
you see see a letter if the price is
going lower right and you see this big
like the red is bigger than the green
you will see it sometimes that will give
you the confidence the price is going to
go lower and it's going to reach my
major my target my major negative gamma
so is that who reveals who is dominant
buyers or Sellers and it help you to
anticipate the next move before it
happens you know Buy on major negative
gamma sell on major positive gamma you
get you know you get to the tick you
guys won't believe but sometimes I trade
like 10 minutes on these levels because
my risk is so small and my you know my
potential profits are huge and and I
know even Advanced Quant Traders use
this tool for a reason because it works
right why because if you track who is in
control right you can position yourself
in the right side of the market so don't
don't you know I don't believe on moving
average or anything like that because
they're lagging indicators I used to
work for an investment Bank in London
and once I learned how to code in Python
the first thing my boss told me to do is
go and do a code who can combine 10 or
12 indicators and get me the best one we
have like 12,000
interactions none of them work you know
RSI with nine simple moving average or
the 50 moving average with the macd name
it we have like 12,000 interactions none
of them work um so this works sorry this
works because listen this is to know who
is moving the market when are they
moving the market where are they putting
their positions and where are they
taking profits this is that's why this
works and I've been using this for two
years and I'm tell you this works it
works there is no other I mean I don't
think there is any other way that you
can actually have a high probability you
know uh success in the market you need
to follow who is you know you need to
follow these guys I used to be one of
these guys in London and and but not
because I was a big guy and and you know
have big it's only because we have big
flows from from clients big clients
central banks big institutions hash
funds you know they are the clever ones
all we have to do was you know heding my
Delta selling the spot or buying the
spot and moving the market taking
liquidity so so so that's what I learned
and that's what I understood if I at
that time I said if I ever trade as a
retail I need to follow the big guys I'm
not going to follow RSI or MD or
whatever I have to follow the big guys
and that's what I found getos classic
like two years ago and it's been
amazing so conclusion conclusion and
let's recap so trade with the
institutions not against them you know
watch Major gamma levels positive and
negative you know see zeroa is the
battlefield you know when he moves you
have a cluster you see the battlefield
and once the price Takes One Direction
you know that's the direction that's the
winner has been revealed right aboid by
trade uh sorry avoid but trads by
following Mass gamma change and net get
volume right this ones you know don't
get into a short position if you have
this situation don't go into a long
position if you have this situation and
unless you hit major negative or major
positive right and also use the zero
gamma to see where the you know where
the market is more likely to keep
going well and getos classic the codes
who is in control of the market simple
tool yet so effective right okay guys if
you found this valuable make sure you
know to like my uh the Youtube video and
if you got any questions just drop a
comment you can send me an email and if
you want me to break down in more
advanced get bug strategies with the
state or order flow you know you let me
know let me know where we are we also
have the getb guys they have a channel
as well um I think when you have the
subscription you can get into the
Discord you you drop an a message to
them and and they are always happen they
are always happy sorry to answer
questions I talk a lot with j and Jon
which are the founders of gubo and I
don't know how they do it but they're
trading they're coding and they're also
they're replying every single question
in the Discord Channel okay guys so
trade the smart follow the real Market
Movers and stay ahead of the game uh
this was Freddy sento thank you so much
for listening any questions I'll be here
cheers guys